every Marvel Superhero dies in this
comic and hears exactly how it happens
but the thing about this is that what we
know is in Marvel Comics you had
something called The Ultimate Universe
that universe is dead and destroyed the
only survivors of it were Miles Morales
and ultimate Reed Richards what ultimate
Reed Richards did is he jumped into the
Multiverse and tried to find his own
reality he ended up stopping Peter
Parker from becoming Spider-Man by
preventing him from being bitten by the
radioactive spider but outside of that
we didn't know what was going on now
there are huge differences in this
universe right now number one Thor never
becomes the king of Asgard instead Loki
becomes the King after Odin dies number
two the bifrost bridge is destroyed so
Asgard is cut off from basically
everything in existence number three the
Fantastic Four are completely and
totally non-existent they were destroyed
during their flight and number four Tony
Stark never became Iron Man instead
Howard Stark never died and he invented
the Iron Man suit not only that he's
best friends with Obadiah stain who did
not exist as far as I know and the
original Ultimate Universe now why is
this universe so different from the
original Ultimate Universe in Marvel
because this is not the Ultimate
Universe this is a reality called Earth
6160. what's basically happened here is
Ultimate Reed Richards stumbled across
this universe and what he's doing is
reworking the entirety of this reality
to try to turn it into the Ultimate
Universe now another big difference here
is that Steve Rogers Captain America
doesn't exist there's seemingly no super
soldier formula here so again massive
differences but what this does is this
basically focuses on the opening of
What's called the city and this is a
gigantic time skip I'll explain why this
time skip matters here in a little bit
but the city is basically a giant Dome
whereby ultimate read can effectively
Fast Track evolution time passes
differently in the dome than it does in
the outside world so basically my house
and the way this works is that as this
Dome is opened up anyone who's anybody
shows up here one of the cool things
about this is that the Incredible Hulk
does exist in this reality but unlike
the Incredible Hulk from the original
Ultimate Universe who is like this
mindless Savage beast and was a cannibal
in this he's a pacifist and in fact he
has a kind of cult built around him so
he's not the Hulk that we traditionally
know now the X-Men also exists in this
alternate reality but we don't really
know how they came into existence but as
this entire celebration and this opening
of the Dome opens Reed looks to the sky
and simply says well I'm waiting and
when that happens a gigantic time portal
opens up and a whole host of variations
of all the superheroes that we know all
come pouring out different versions of
Thor Captain America so on and so forth
and they all launch in attack now with
Howard Stark being the one who created
the Iron Man suit he doesn't have it on
him because this is supposed to be a day
for him to relax but Obadiah stain does
something to understand Howard Stark is
Iron Man Obadiah stain is basically War
Machine what's so crazy about this is
that in the midst of the attack all the
different superheroes say we have to get
Reed and any other essential Personnel
everybody else don't kill them if you
don't have to but hey collateral damage
happens that's one of the big
distinctions between the main Marvel
Universe and the Ultimate Universe and
the original Ultimate Universe in Marvel
Comics while superheroes wouldn't really
intend to kill people they were a lot
more Cavalier about the loss of life
through collateral damage which is to
say it wasn't that big of a deal to them
but in the midst of this gigantic fight
with Obadiah stain doing what he can
where he can when he can he's ultimately
killed in the conflict Howard Stark is
knocked unconscious and when he wakes up
he stands in the presence of ultimate
read also known as the maker the and
this is when everything gets cool and
this is when we start finding out
exactly what's going on so something to
know is Howard Stark is incredibly
intelligent here but when he comes to he
basically wakes up in this room with all
these different superheroes that it
invaded basically being held captive and
what ultimate Reed says is that because
of the nature of the city they've been
able to break down and understand
perfectly how human DNA works just a
testament to how intelligent this
version of Reed Richards is and so what
he deduces is that what someone seems to
be doing is that they're either creating
superheroes in the future and sending
them into the past to destroy ultimate
Reed Richards or all these different
superheroes are just the same person but
from different points in time they could
be separated by one day they could be
separated by five years there's no
definitive way to know for sure and
honestly it doesn't matter the reason
why is because Reed says that in
analyzing their DNA that they are all
basically in some capacity either based
on or are The Offspring of humans that
exist out in the world right now and so
Reed gathered all these humans together
brought them into a room and killed him
on the spot and then it becomes a
grandfather Paradox if you guys are
familiar with that if you went back in
time and you killed your grandfather How
Could You Be Alive to go back in time
and so what this means is that with the
basis behind all these future
superheroes basically being destroyed
they can't exist and so they simply
break down into like a giant pool of
genetic goo they basically stop existing
and so this blows Howard Stark's mind
and it seems like this astronomically
gruesome thing to do and so in response
to this Reed says I want to show you
something and so he brings him into a
room and shows him what he calls the
immortus machine now one of the things
that I want to establish here is that
the ultimate universe as it was
originally done in Marvel Comics was
designed to match closer to the real
world so you're not really going to have
things like a true immortus or Kane the
Conqueror that sits at the very edge of
time and jumps back to the modern era
and fights the Avengers and so on and so
forth when you're talking about things
like immortus it's more represented as
the concept of time travel as opposed to
a guy who can time travel it's not to
say they can't because this device is
literally a time travel device Howard
Stark picks up on that immediately and
that's when he starts to deduce that's
why people are coming after you because
you're making changes in this universe's
history and by changing the past you're
changing the future so they're coming
from the future to try to stop you to
keep you from potentially ending their
existence or any number of things and so
that's when Howard asked the most
logical question what stops them from
going back in time and killing your
parents before you were born and the
responsive ultimate read is because I'm
not from this universe I'm turning your
Universe into what used to be my
universe I'm basically reworking your
entire history that's all this is right
that's the idea behind this is that the
Ultimate Universe is dead and gone
there's no way to bring it back instead
the best you could potentially hope for
is to travel to an alternate reality and
reshape the historical events of that
Universe to turn it into your own that's
why all of this is happening in the
first place that's why he literally says
do you believe that this world that you
live in right now is the way that it was
supposed to be it's not I've made
changes to everything I stopped Peter
Parker from becoming Spider-Man I put
Loki on the throne of Asgard instead of
Thor I led to the destruction of the
bifrost bridge I got the Fantastic Four
killed all these things have happened
because of my intervention and so when
Howard Stark starts asking questions and
says like just it's unconscionable what
you're doing the amount of wherewithal
and the amount of effort it would take
to modify an entire time stream and
change everything to annihilate a whole
future just to turn the present into
what you want it to be it's got to be
insane and he says this was just your
first encounter I can't imagine what
happens next and the response of read is
no it's the second encounter this is my
second attempt at doing this the first
one was two weeks ago and when he
removes his helmet what he shows is that
half of his face is basically blown off
that seemingly the first time that
Howard Stark had met Reed Richards he
almost killed him he blew half of his
head apart and so what's basically going
on to kind of clear this up a little bit
is that it is in effect a Time Loop that
when ultimate read first showed up to
this universe he tried to modify and he
tried to change things popped off he was
attacked by Iron Man he used the
Immortals machine to go back and try
again this is the second attempt but
this time the machine is slightly
damaged and so what he tells Howard is I
need your help with this and when the
response of Howard is why would I help
you with this machine the responsive
read is because I believe you're the one
that helped me build this I don't
remember for sure because ever since the
attack between you and myself and half
my head is gone my memories aren't
working the way that they're supposed to
so I'm not even fully aware of what's
happened before but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end if
you want to get caught up or you feel
yourself a little bit lost click the
link to this video this will take you to
the first video that we did any
questions you have post them down in the
comments make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoyed the video and I
will catch you all later
peace